The Myers–Briggs Type Indicator
is a self-assessment of how we
perceive the world and make decisions.
The test measures our preferences in
4 domains: sources of mental energy,
processing of information, approach to
decision-making, and need for structure.
Each of the four categories has two
sides: extroversion or introversion,
sensing or intuition, thinking or
feeling, and judging or perceiving.
This then results in 16
possible personality types.
Before we begin the test, keep 3 things in mind:
Human traits exist on a spectrum: you could fall
in the center of two extremes and get different
results when repeating the test later.
The MBTI looks at preferences. So
people who prefer extraversion over
introversion may not be extraverts,
they simply like that personality type better.
Don’t take the results too seriously.
To determine your type, ask
yourself these 4 questions.
Do you focus outwardly or inwardly?
Are you rather outgoing or private?
Do you speak impulsively or thoughtfully?
Do you get energized being around
others or do you recharge alone?
Do you prefer extraversion or introversion??
How do you prefer to take in information?
Do you focus on how things are or
imagine how things could be?
Do you pay attention to concrete
details or do you see the big picture?
Do you prefer practical ideas or
enjoy theories for their own sake?
Do you favor sensing or intuition?
How do you like to make decisions?
Do you rely on logic or personal values?
Do you prioritize fairness and
justice or forgiveness and harmony?
Do you enjoy finding flaws in
arguments or agreeing with others?
Do you like thinking or feeling?
How do you prefer to live your outer life?
Do you want matters settled or options open?
Do you think rules need to be
respected or see them as suggestions?
Do you like detailed instructions
or prefer improvisation?
Do you like judging or perceiving?
Now that you know who you are, you can take the
letters representing extraversion, introversion,
sensing, intuition, thinking, feeling, judging,
and perceiving and form your type, say ESTJ.
What that means, becomes clear when
we look at the 16 personality types.
ESTPs enjoy being around people and focus on the
here and now. Their minds are quick, intelligent,
and outspoken. Good at reading others, they
can solve complex problems. Routines bore them,
and they see rules as recommendations.
They are often called doers.
ESTJs prefer things settled and are not
interested in abstract ideas. They value
security and are also known as guardians.
At work, they are capable of organizing,
getting things done, and are loyal
colleagues who don’t miss small
important details. To keep things neat,
they want everyone to follow the protocol.
ESFPs are friendly, social, and accepting.
They love to have new experiences and meet
new people. ESPFs enjoy seeing others happy and
as a result, are often the center of attention.
Disliking analysis, they have plenty of common
sense. Instead of logic, they are driven by
values and hence tend to agree with people
they like. They are also called performers.
ESFJs are warm-hearted and cooperative. They
feel a strong sense of duty, value traditions,
and are loyal friends. At work, they are
detailed and tend to complete tasks accurately
and on time. Their empathy allows them to
see what others need, which makes them good
leaders. ESFJs want to be appreciated for
who they are and are known as caregivers.
ENFPs are known as enthusiastic idealists
who see a life full of possibilities. Their
minds are spontaneous, creative, and are
able to do almost anything that interests
them — although the affirmation of their peers
greatly influences their behavior. At work,
ENFPs are fast thinkers, and good
at improvising. But they do get
bored with details or things they don’t
care about. Some call them inspirers.
ENFJs are warm, responsive, and able to take
responsibility. They show outstanding people
skills and see plenty of potential in others.
This makes them good managers and inspiring
leaders. Since they are concerned about how others
think and feel, they are also known as givers.
ENTPs are intellectually quick, creative,
and good at a broad range of things. They
get excited about new projects but are so
bored by routines that they rarely do the
same thing the same way. Their ability
to read others, think strategically,
and solve complex problems, makes them
stimulating friends. Some call them visionaries.
ENTJs tend to be confident, frank, and quick
to make a decision. They value competence and
have no patience for nonsense. At work, they
are quick to spot poor organizational design
and are able to create intelligent new
solutions. They like to make long-term
plans and then implement them no matter what.
That’s one reason some call them executives.
And now those who prefer introverts.
ISTJs are calm, serious, and interested
in peaceful living. Their judgment is
thorough and realistic. They
like to keep things organized,
are hardworking, and are focused
on achieving what they set out to.
The fact that they are loyal, reliable, and
detailed gave them the nickname inspectors.
ISTPs are reserved and relaxed until there is
a problem. Then, they act quickly and usually
find a good solution. Their curiosity about
how things work makes them good analysts and
great engineers. Their thinking is structured
and logical, but not afraid to break the rules
if they get in the way of them doing something
extraordinary. They are known as the mechanics.
ISFJs are introverts that are conscientious and
kind. They often have a high degree of empathy and
remember specifics about their friends. At work,
they are committed to meeting their obligations
and like to see everyone happy. Interested
in serving others, they are called nurturers.
ISFPs are serious, sensitive, and good-hearted.
They are very loyal friends and committed to
their personal values. Conflicts stress them out,
which is why they don’t like to lead or control
others. Their sense of time and appreciation
for beauty gave them the alias artists.
INFJs are sensitive, original, and the rarest of
all types. Their strong intuition means that they
trust their instincts above all else. They prefer
neither leading nor following but doing what feels
right. Their devotion to protecting what they
value earned them the pseudonym defenders.
INFPs are reflective, loyal, and often idealistic.
Their primary goal is to find out their meaning
in life — to make the world a better place. At
work, they like to help and are quick to spot
possibilities to make things better. Interested in
serving humanity, they are also called idealists.
INTJs have minds that are original, independent,
and analytical. At work, they think long-term,
are determined, and show a high standard of
competence - for themselves and others. This
makes them natural leaders. Their knowledge and
cognitive ability gave them the alias scientists.
INTPs are creative and rational and get excited
about theories and ideas. Their tendency to be
quiet makes them hard to read. Although when
they focus on problems they find interesting,
they often reveal their true
character. They have natural
skepticism and logical explanations for
almost everything. They are called thinkers.
The building blocks of the original MBTI were
laid by Katharine Briggs and her daughter Isabel
Briggs Myers who based their work on Carl Jung’s
`influential 1921 theory of psychological types’.
What do you think? Can we
divide individuals into 2, 4,
8 or 16 personality types and then infer
who they are? Share your thoughts in the
comments below. To do an MBTI test right
now, look for the link in the description.
If you found this helpful, check
out our other videos and subscribe.
If you want to support our work,
join us on patreon.com/sprouts.
For more information and additional
contents, visit sproutsschools.com